the air we breathe in normal times it's
something we can take for granted but
like so many things coronavirus has
changed that air conditioning systems
are suspected of a role in a series of
outbreaks now businesses are going to
extraordinary lengths to reassure us
that their air is safe nowhere is that
more the case than in the skies with
passengers packed together taking in re
filtered air so what will it take for us
to breathe easily again with summer on
the horizon many of us will be tempted
to switch on the air conditioning to
cool down but recent in size of a
Harvard infectious disease expert
suggests that air conditioning use
across the southern United States may be
a factor in spiking kovat 19 cases plus
a corona virus outbreak in a German meat
plant was also linked to cooling systems
so how safe is the air we are breathing
[Music]
a common sight for these coronavirus
times people pouring off public
transport wearing face masks looking for
that first goal of fresh air masks in
many places are compulsory but as the
weather gets warmer
is that enough to ease worries
I feel if I have a mask in my children
and I try to make sure that I'm like one
and a half or two meters away from
somebody who also has masks I feel quite
sure see it can't be too safe
if you want to get it around this is
what you have to do
most modern trams and buses are fitted
with air-conditioning units which draw
fresh air from the outside but go
underground and it's a slightly
different story though passenger numbers
are still down compared to before the
pandemic carriages are starting to fill
up again in confined spaces without much
ventilation these are considered higher
risk despite the lack of air
conditioning transport officials point
to other sources of airflow so they use
a lot of outside air to ventilate the
vehicles the whole time they're going
and they're driving then of course at
the stations the doors open up so you
have ventilation there the station's
itself are ventilated by the trains
going back and forth cuz they have these
huge trains pushing in with a speed
moving out the air a corona virus
outbreak is a meat plant in northern
Germany has put air conditioning under
the spotlight again it follows a Chinese
study that suggested air conditioning
helped spread the virus to diners in a
Guangzhou restaurant the air
conditioning has a movement of the air
they can transfer the the droplets of
the viruses from one to the other
therefore you need much more air fresh
air from the outside in such cases
scientists admit it's too early to make
any firm conclusions about air
conditioning units as well as fresh air
they say high efficiency filters can
help reduce the presence of the virus
such filters are what airlines use
inside their cabins recycling the air
flow every three or four minutes but
this only kicks in during the flight and
not before and after
these air conditions has to be active
before the passion passengers entered
the plane we think that air dry air
promotes a formation of aerosols and
consequently the possibility of an
infection as summer and the holiday
season approaches this year there's more
than simply just the destination to
consider well for more let's bring in
yunchan he's a mechanical engineering
professor at Purdue University in the US
state of Indiana and the editor in chief
of the academic journal building and
environment welcome to DW young the
scientific community seems to be
undecided when it comes to air
conditioning systems and the coronavirus
do you think they are safe to use during
a pandemic
thank you very much encouraged to ever
be me here the air conditioning system
in general I think is so what is safe
however the air distribution leaving the
air conditioning system and in a
buildings in airplanes and so on could
apropos a certain type of risks okay can
you tell us how and why yes for example
when you come when you call you generate
a lot of a droplet and lots of trouble
that will go within the air inside of an
enclosed space and this typically will
wonder for about three to four minutes
in the airplane and tend to tell - a in
buildings and this job letter will be
there and then you will breathe in if
you stay in the same room with a Sega
patient and then you make the catalyst
probably the 19 okay now airlines are
saying it is safe to fly because they
use special filters which the airline's
claim clean almost 100% of the air
aboard a plane is that true yeah it is -
lately airplane usually high-efficiency
particulate filter or HEPA filter which
can filter out particulate with a
diameter of 0.3 micron or larger so in
principle you can filter out all the
viruses
in here however and the information
could just occur inside of an airplane
so before the area is being shuttered
out by the air conditioning system as I
just mentioned during Lisa 3 to 4
minutes you'll have a very high chance
to get invited hmm okay when it's about
the filters that are a key here can they
be used in other places like public
transport like office buildings yes in
principle Lisa HEPA filters can be used
in any air conditioning systems however
that's a problem because when you use a
HEPA filter they you know neither were a
powerful thing in order to push the air
soon now most of the buildings public
transportation systems like train passes
or several ways they are not equipped
with Lisa powerful fan so when you use a
HEPA filter that means that you will
have much less air so that's also a
dilemma to use allahabad filters unless
you really make a overall change to have
a very powerful fence there okay are
these fans being worked on to integrate
them into regular air conditioning
systems in the air conditioning systems
we do have a normal fence but lots of
fans are typically only working together
with the low efficiency filters and a
low efficiency field is typically
installed in the buildings are normally
good because even let's not condemn 'ok
you have no problem with that but the
during the pandemic of casa you have a
very small virus and which could be
recirculated in air conditioning systems
and now you might not be able to stop
that and yeah in general when it comes
to air conditioning what can companies
do to lower the risk of infection for
their employees working in offices now
let's great question Chris and the first
thing you definitely want to do able to
see you can install any high-efficiency
HEPA filters there and I thought because
it might not be possible
in a second way if you have to run
air-conditioning systems
I will recommend that you use 100% of
outside of air because the outside air
is unlikely to contain any copy the 19
butters so you surprised just outside of
here will be what you say furthermore if
you could open windows they will be
great because the natural ventilation is
very good to reduce the lead
concentration of the virus the inside of
our spaces and if you could also
consider to buy a HEPA filter inside a
lockable for air cleaner because the
last type of air cleaner is also very
efficient in getting out of the
particulate ends up let's yeah chairman
is a mechanical engineering professor at
Purdue University
yeah thank you for your insights thank
you very much please and now it is over
to another expert in his field
our science correspond to Derrick
Williams answering the questions you
sent us I've heard different numbers for
the longevity of Czar's Cove two on
different surfaces what's the scientific
evidence behind it almost all of the
citations you find about numbers in this
area eventually lead you back to one
study that was published in mid-april
in in the New England Journal of
Medicine the researchers behind it
conducted a series of tests with Sarris
Cove two on surfaces made from different
materials and and their findings have
been widely accepted as guidelines since
then the scientists concluded that the
virus was was most stable on plastic
where it was was still viable at least
in small amounts after three days that's
followed by by stainless steel where it
was still measurable after two on
cardboard on the other hand it was no
longer detectable after 24 hours those
figures are roughly consistent with what
had been observed about about viability
in a related pathogen
the corona virus that causes SARS and
and they've now been widely accepted as
a as a rule of thumb I haven't seen any
further research disputing them so how
dangerous are surfaces do we need to
disinfect everything that comes into the
home so if the virus can remain viable
for up to three days on some surfaces um
how much of a threat do those surfaces
pose objects that have been contaminated
and later transfer a disease are known
as fomites and there's been a lot of
discussion about how big a role they're
playing in the current pandemic
increasingly though the consensus is
that that foe might transmission is the
exception rather than the norm that's
because a whole sequence of events has
to happen for it to occur starting with
the smearing of significant amounts of
the virus on a surface by it by someone
who's infected when the clock starts
ticking as it begins to lose viability
frequently touch surfaces like doorknobs
or or elevator buttons pose more of a
threat than say a carton of milk from
the store but even if you pick the virus
up on your hands you still have to
actively transport it to your face
within a certain time frame and not wash
your hands in the interim in comparison
you just have to be close enough to
someone shedding the virus as an aerosol
and to breathe it in and to catch the
disease that way so so most experts and
health authorities say now that although
foam eye transmission is possible a
kovat 19:00 spreads much more easily
person-to-person
you